good morning I'm Brian McQuaid I'm a
software engineer at Google I work on
making the mobile web faster and better
and today I'm going to talk about
building instant mobile web apps so
we'll take the next 30 minutes to cover
two topics the first will be I'll give
an overview of the process my team
actually took to optimize one of the
apps I work on and then the second half
will sort of take from that some some
learnings or some generalizations and
best practices that hopefully you can
take with you to make your mobile apps
faster okay so our goal specifically
more precisely is to render app content
on the phone in a second so from the
time a user sort of clicks a link to the
time they actually sort of start to see
content on your phone and to interact
with it should be about a second and
this one second target actually comes
from some work linked here at the bottom
by Jakob Nielsen hopefully you can see
that that talks about some different
thresholds of human perception you know
we're sort of behavior changes and that
one-second boundary is interesting
because that's the point at which a user
will start to sort of disengage with
with you know the activity they've
initiated they'll start to think about
doing something else and so to keep the
user engaged to keep them you know
wanting to use your app we want to try
to deliver that content as quickly as
possible
ideally within that roughly one second
boundary so a lot of this a lot of what
I'm going to talk about is sort of
focuses on this concept of the critical
rendering path which you may have heard
Ilya talk about or others talked about
at a really high level the critical
rendering path is sort of the sequence
of resources that need to be loaded and
parsed usually JavaScript and stylesheet
resources that prevent content on the
page from actually rendering from the
screen right so so actually it's easiest
to sort of explain I think with an
example okay so here along the top we've
got kind of a timeline that shows how an
example page that I'm using for this
example renders over time out to 20
seconds on a mobile device so we have a
performance problem here and the
question becomes well why is it so slow
right you know why is it taking nine
seconds to render anything to the screen
and why does it take 20 seconds to sort
of finish rendering and that's what the
critical rendering path sort of tries to
answer
so if we have an example network
waterfall here we can kind of walk
through and try to start to make sense
of what this critical rendering path is
all about so we obviously we start by
loading HTML resource that comes back
with some content I might have a
stylesheet with a script resource and so
at this point we have sort of like I
said you know the critical path includes
usually scripting styles these resources
block the browser from actually painting
content to the screen so well a style
sheet is pending the browser is going to
wait for that stylesheet to load before
it actually paints any content to the
screen so we can't paint anything until
these resources finish loading
imagine that you know we send out the
request for both of those the response
comes back to the JavaScript at nine
seconds and at that point you know we
can begin to paint something to the
screen right it may not be the content
the user actually wants unfortunately
that's sort of at the end but we've sort
of started to paint and then from there
imagine that javascript resource adds
CSS resource to the dom a stylesheet to
the dom and so you know now that's on
the critical path for sort of subsequent
paints once that loads we can see you
know we can paint a little bit more
content the stylesheet maybe had some
stylings for the footer additionally you
know we've loaded a say a second
JavaScript resource from that first
JavaScript resource and say that's used
actually render the sort of main content
in the screen and so that now has to
load parse and execute before we can
actually see any content on the screen
or I'm sorry see the final content and
then finally around 19 or 20 seconds all
of that finishes that whole sort of
process of you know these things loading
in the browser finishes and we can paint
the sort of finished content to the
screen and show that to the user so the
critical rendering path tries to sort of
focus on the most significant resources
that cause render blocking and explain
sort of you know why we see these delays
but this becomes especially important on
mobile where we have these very high
network around trip times and loading
extra javascript and CSS resources ends
up you know having a significant cost so
now we'll focus more on sort of thing
about optimizing the critical path we
know here that we've got this really
long critical path of resources this is
just a toy example but so the question
becomes well how do we actually address
and optimize that and I'm going to talk
about the process my team went through
about a year ago to do just that
for one of the apps I work on PageSpeed
insights so PageSpeed insights is a tool
you can use that
developers.google.com/plus PageSpeed
this is a tool where you can enter a URL
into the box here we go off and we
render the page in a headless browser we
analyze how it loads and we come back
and give you a sort of prioritized list
of recommendations to make the page load
faster and about a year ago we had this
problem well we started to think about
okay you know how do we make this page
really fast on mobile we knew we weren't
doing great but the first thing we did
was we wanted to see exactly how how
poorly we were doing right and so what
we saw really surprised us it was it was
worse than we expected you know now you
can see where the example comes from I
took nine seconds to render anything at
all but it took about 19 or 20 seconds
on a 3G connection on an iPhone 4 in
this case to render what the user
actually cared about which was that
initial text box that they could use to
interact with the app and so you know 20
seconds our target is one second we've
got something a really significant
problem here and we knew we needed to
really sort of rethink a lot or try to
figure out what we had missed right this
app was reasonably fast on desktop but
on a you know high latency mobile
connection you know just took way too
long to load so we started to look at
the markup you know we saw we had some
render blocking resources in the head
but this isn't all that uncommon right
you see this in lots of apps so there's
nothing that really stood out here as
being particularly costly so we went
back to our time line then we looked at
a network waterfall right you can see we
load about 25 resources here and the
question came up you know okay well
we're loading all these resources but
which of these resources are actually
contributing to making the page slower
you know which of these are on sort of
the critical rendering path right and so
one of the things that PageSpeed
insights actually does today is it can
tell you what what resource which
resources are on the critical rendering
path and so we can go here we can click
through and we can see you know we've
got these JavaScript resources these CSS
resources that are on that critical
rendering path that block rendering of
content on the screen and then use that
to go back to our waterfall and start to
focus on you know which resources
actually block rendering right so now we
have
about a dozen resources to focus on and
we know we're able to focus more
precisely on you know what are the
render blocking effects of these
resources and then how do we address
those and so we can begin to sort of
match up here right we've got some
content that loads before this sort of 9
second first pane we can start to notice
you know okay well you know which of
those resources are blocking that point
I'll get into that in just a minute but
this was sort of the starting point for
us was sort of looking at this and
figuring out okay well you know how do
we optimize the critical rendering path
for this page and so you know we at a
high level we felt like we had sort of
two two problems here one was that we
had a bunch of render blocking
JavaScript and CSS loaded in a way that
blocked any content at all from
rendering the page rendering on the page
right so this block of this block of
JavaScript and CSS here which was you
know declared in the head of the HTML
all had to be downloaded parsed and
executed in order for anything at all to
render on the screen right and as we
know mobile networks have really high
latency so you know downloading
additional resources has a pretty
significant you know pretty high cost
all the while your users are you know
looking at a blank screen waiting and
wondering if your app is working
thinking about transitioning way to do
something else right so for us and I'll
show in a little more detail in a minute
what we concluded we needed to do is
basically eliminate all of these
resources from render being render
blocking and that amounted to doing two
things which will dive into loading our
render blocking JavaScript
asynchronously and then really thinking
about what is the minimal amount of CSS
we actually need to render this out and
loading that in a blocking way but
making sure we weren't loading any more
than we needed in a render blocking way
and then right and so recall this as the
screen shot that sort of was associated
with that point in the in the in the
page load thing to note here is that you
know we hadn't actually rendered the
content the user really cared about that
text box to interact with the app yet so
the second issue was we were actually
rendering that sort of critical content
the text box you know the user could use
to actually analyze a page using a
JavaScript resource right we had to
download a large chunk of JavaScript
download parse and execute that
JavaScript before we actually render
that you know using javascript to
construct the dom so this added another
roughly you know ten seconds of latency
here before we could get to this point
so all in all you know we had sort of
two at a high level these two problems
and so we sat down and we tried to sort
of address these things the thing we did
for this was we realized well you know
most of the content you know we're
rendering it with JavaScript and that's
fine and great but it just wasn't
performant and so what we did is we
inlined that initial view right so the
or I should say we put the initial views
HTML markup directly in the HTML no
longer depending on JavaScript to
actually render that which allowed us to
you know just present that to the user
that much faster without having to wait
for that render blocking JavaScript to
load so I just want to show a quick
before-and-after you know here's that
HTML markup for the original page that
took 19 seconds at least part of it
right we've got our render blocking
JavaScript in the head we've got some
markup for the content but we don't have
you'll notice the input box right that
was rendered with JavaScript so some of
that comes later the sort of after case
here we've got a slightly different
markup right first we've got an inline
style block that contains the CSS we
need to style the content the initial
view so we don't have to go to network
to download additional style sheets
which you know will incur additional
mobile network round trips which are
significantly slower or significantly
slow down the page load and then as I
mentioned you know now we've made sure
that all the markup we need to render
this sort of above the fold content is
directly in HTML we're not using
javascript to render any of this content
and then finally you know because we're
including all the markup we need to
render the initial view directly in HTML
we can load our JavaScript
asynchronously because we don't need it
to render so we don't want it to block
rendering of the initial presentation so
that at a high level is the process we
went through and so the question is you
know how do we do do we actually speed
the page up so here's the waterfall for
the original page we've got about 25
resources in total and then here's the
waterfall for this sort of rewrite that
was focused on
delivering a really fast experience on
mobile and you can see we've got about
20 resources now right so we had 25
before 20 now it's not really
significantly different if you look at
the total waterfall size total number
requests right but but I think what's
really important here is looking not at
the total number of quests but the
relative size of the two critical paths
between the critical rendering path
between the two pages right so in the
old example we had a bunch of resources
here we've got everything we need to
render the initial view in the HTML
payload so the critical path the
critical rendering path is this one HTML
resource and we can render you know much
more quickly than in the original case
where we had a dozen resources so we
often talk about you know well okay
reducing requests is sort of a goal and
with performance and with optimisation
but I think what's more important is to
think about reducing the number of
requests on the critical rendering path
that's really where you you know will
see your big returns so let's look let's
do a sort of a side-by-side you know
before and after so the optimized case
we start to render in about a second and
a half and we're completely done at
three seconds all the images everything
have come back and recall the original
case you know we're still waiting right
we can't actually really interact with
the app even at this point because we
don't have the text box right so we were
able to reduce the you know render time
down from about you know 20 seconds down
to one or one and a half seconds right
so we more or less accomplished our goal
so that's you know the process we went
through and now I'm going to spend a
little time talking about the process of
optimizing your apps content so you know
what do we learn what are the general
best practices there how can you deliver
this instant experience for your users
on mobile so the first thing we learn -
the first thing we sort of identified as
an important best practice is to load
scripts asynchronously right so don't
load scripts in a way that blocks
rendering because on mobile networks
with the high you know high latency high
round-trip times each additional
resource you load in the critical
rendering path pushes out the time the
user has to wait you know to sort of
start interacting with your app you know
pretty significantly right so here we've
got your sort of standard page script
source equals all that j/s in the head
right and we've got the content right
beneath it
you know the browser receives that at
the same time probably as the script but
it can't show it to the user
until the script has finished
downloading parsing and executing on the
mobile device
which introduced really significant you
know additional render latency is for
the user right and so what do we do in
the best case you can take advantage of
the html5 async tag which tells the
browser yes I need this script right so
I need to load this script but it's not
you don't need to sort of execute it in
line at the point where it appears in
the document you know execute it
sometime later when it finishes
downloading and then go ahead and just
proceed parsing the rest of the document
and render that content to the user as
quickly as you can right so this this
gets scripts out of the critical
rendering path which is a really
important thing to do so I'll say there
are some subtleties here it's not it's
often not quite as easy as just dropping
a sync tag in there if you use document
dot write in order dot in JavaScript
this is a really dangerous thing to do
and there are other you know sort of
subtleties that I'd be happy to talk
about at the sort of session and I guess
it'll be 45 minutes so ii rendered the
initial view server-side is HTML you
know you'll recall we had about six
seconds of render blocking javascript
and CSS but then we had ten seconds to
load you know that final javascript
resource download parse and executed
before the app finished rendering right
and the problem was we were loading this
big javascript bundle whose job it was
to actually construct the dom right so
we have to go to network in order to
create the dom that the user would see
and this is just unfortunately an
inherently slow process on mobile
rendering client-side so I'll let's talk
about so what do we mean by server-side
rendering versus client-side rendering
so client-side rendering you're using
JavaScript right to actually render the
content in the document right so here we
load app j/s the dom itself doesn't
really contain any markup it doesn't
contain market that you can see on the
screen it's just got a placeholder div
and then when app dot j s finishes
loading we might get something like this
that actually constructs the dom you
know once that resource finishes loading
right by contrast
server-side rendering you know
everything that we need to display in
the initial view is present right in the
HTML markup and so no additional
resources are needed right as soon as
that HTML comes back we can render that
to the screen and the user sees it as
quickly as possible right so this is
just a mobile especially this is just a
much more performant approach for the
initial view so certainly you know once
the app is finished loading and the
users interacting with your app you know
they're changing the way the content is
presented right maybe they're navigating
through a menu certainly at that point
it makes sense to use javascript to
construct your document but for that
initial view you should do as much
server-side rendering to HTML as you
possibly can so that we found this to be
true we weren't the only ones twitter
also encountered the same sort came to
the same conclusion so they wrote a blog
post about a year ago where they talked
about this in 2010 they'd released new
Twitter where all the rendering happened
on the client right and they talked
about you know that that allowed them to
do some interesting new things but it
came at the consequence of significant
sort of regression in sort of actual
client-side render time right so in 2012
they wrote this blog post where they
talked about taking back control of
front-end performance by moving
rendering back to the server and what
they found okay is that you know page
load times drop really significant area
so it wasn't like 10% or 15% it was 1/5
of what they were previously right so
this is a really big thing for them in
order to deliver that instant experience
on mobile it's pretty much a requirement
that you that you render that initial
view server-side so Twitter wasn't the
only organization to sort of come to
this conclusion
Airbnb had a very similar conclusion in
a blog post earlier this year they said
you know under their old design the
external JavaScript files had to
download evaluate and execute you know
only then with the apps were discover oh
the users intent was to do X it would
call it to the API you know which is
additional in that request that you know
server became part of that critical
rendering path here we are on a mobile
connection which has really high latency
which led to for them a time to content
rights at a time until the user could
sort of get the content that they wanted
of up
ten seconds in sort of you know in bad
cases so then they switch the
server-side rendering which by the way
they open-source the infrastructure they
use for this so it's it's worth a look
at this blog post when they move to
serving the you know initial view as
HTML generated on the server it don't
find that five times faster so similar
conclusion right Twitter one-fifth here
Airbnb five times faster right so in my
opinion if you want to deliver a truly
instant experience and it's you know
there's a trade-off right you really
need so if you want to deliver that
instant experience on mobile you really
need to be server-side rendering that
initial view loading JavaScript to
create the initial presentation it's
just going to be too slow on mobile for
it to be an instant experience right and
we saw Twitter and Airbnb both had
really dramatic speed reductions as a
result of adopting this technique so I
would say you know when choosing a
JavaScript framework you want to look
for a framework ideally that supports
server-side rendering right air BnB
talked about the one they open-source
not all the JavaScript frameworks out
there today do support this but if
you're using one today that you do like
that doesn't support server-side
rendering you should push on the
development team or you know pitch in
and help out to make it easy to do that
as part of you know using that framework
so you can take advantage of this
automatically so the third area I want
to talk about is minimizing render
blocking CSS and this is I think this is
the topic we get the most questions on
so I'm going to go through a couple
common questions here the first of which
you know people say well what do you
mean CSS is blocking you know why is
this part of this blocking critical
rendering path JavaScript locks yes but
what do you mean CSS blocks and it's
correct that you know JavaScript blocks
down create dom tree construction right
javascript blocks the parser but
stylesheets block render tree
construction right so ultimately in
order to layout in paint we need the
stylesheet to have finished loading and
what your users care about is content
painted to the screen right so for them
javascript is read I'm sorry style
sheets are render blocking right so it's
important to sort of keep this in mind
right if you load a large stylesheet in
the head that's going to delay the time
it takes to paint content to the screen
so
ja CSS is render blocking so what's
critical CSS what is this we talked
about this concept of critical CSS you
may have heard it sort of goes along
with the critical rendering path and how
to identify my critical CSS so critical
CSS you can think of as the minimal CSS
you need to actually sort of position
and style content in the initial view of
your app right so everything you need to
present that flash of unstyled content
for the content that you display
initially to the user the idea here is
that because we know CSS is render
blocking we want to minimize the amount
of CSS that we serve up to the user in
order to minimize the sort of size of
the critical path and get the content to
display as quickly as possible so
identifying critical CSS I'll talk about
this people you know people often ask
the question why have all the CSS I need
all of it what do you mean critical you
know how do I know what's critical and
what's not so again critical CSS is that
needed to position in style content the
initial view you know so imagine we have
this alert CSS rule and then we've got
this markup served up in the initial
HTML so it's going to be visible in the
initial view that references that rule
we expect it to look like this on the
page initially right we expected to have
their proper stylings a good way to ask
yourself you know is this critical CSS
or not it's ask well if I took this rule
out of the payload right would my
initial view with the content I serve to
the user initially look correctly and in
this case obviously if we took that rule
out it would sort of get the default
stylings and look totally wrong right so
clearly we need the CSS to style content
in the initial view thus it is critical
CSS and we want to serve it up early in
a render blocking way so imagine we
changed our HTML markup there so you can
see before it was span classes was alert
now we decide okay we don't really want
a mark hello world as an alert it's just
a normal
sniffing of text we want it to be styled
as such at this point so imagine though
that we do use the alert class later in
the app right like imagine your users
interacting with the app you know they
try to upload a video
oh it fails you want to show an alert at
that time so we do need it but we don't
need this rule as part of the initial
view at that point right it's not part
of the initial view and so it's no
longer sort of critical and you may want
to think about loading that later
in the app lifecycle in a way that
doesn't block the initial the initial
view so one more bit I think this is
actually probably this is somewhat
subtle but probably the most important
thing when we talk about critical CSS
it's critical you know the critical CSS
is the CSS needed to position and style
the content in the initial view right so
oftentimes we inline data URIs into our
CSS you know the goal being okay let's
reduce the number of requests that my
page makes I can serve the image
separately or I can inline it right into
my CSS and interestingly what what uh
what we are doing when we inline these
data urs for images is we're basically
promoting the image from being non
render blocking right not part of the
critical render path because images by
default they obviously need to download
the image to render the image itself but
images don't block rendering of other
content on the screen when we inline it
as a data URI here we basically promoted
it to being render blocking to being a
part of the critical rendering path and
we're making that critical rendering
path that much longer right and so you
know data URIs - they tend to be quite
big right right so here's our markup so
you know if you look at your CSS and
you're using this technique lots of
sites do you'll notice probably the
majority of bytes in your CSS files may
actually be from these inline data URIs
and what you're doing is you're
increasing that critical path link
pretty significantly and actually
causing users to have to wait to see any
content at all on the screen as a result
so you'll actually render the other
content on the screen more quickly if
you just switch back to that you know
either CSS sprite with the external file
reference or you know if you're using
something like speedy where spriting
doesn't really bring you any benefit
just keeping each image assets separate
reducing the size of the CSS reducing
the size of your critical rendering path
and making the page load that much more
quickly this is pretty easy to test out
you know create a simple page and let a
bunch of data uris in a style sheet
create a second version of that page you
know use the technique
where you've got a separate image a set
make sure there's some non image content
on the page all right so put some text
in there whatever it may be and then
compare the two in webpage tasks do a
video comparison on a 3G network and
you'll see that when you in line data
URIs into your stylesheet you're
blocking rendering of all the content on
the page right you're blocking the text
you know whatever it may be so on mobile
again we're you know downloading
additional content the critical
rendering path is expensive I encourage
you know people to not take that
approach except for maybe very small
data URIs right so I would I would say
that you know large data URIs inlined in
render blocking CSS are actually harmful
for rendering performance and I would I
would avoid using that approach so then
a couple more questions how okay so I've
created I've identified my critical CSS
I've removed my data URI as I made it
nice and small how should I load that
critical CSS so there's no there's two
ways to go about this in PageSpeed
insights we actually inline the critical
CSS is a style block inline keeping that
critical rendering path as short as we
can right we don't want to go back to
network to download an external
stylesheet in our case because that
incurs additional network round-trips
which can add anywhere from you know 500
milli to you know maybe a second
depending on how it's loaded of time the
user staring at a blank screen right so
for us we felt like the best approach
was to inline the CSS needed to style
the initial view directly in our HTML
payload but I wouldn't say that's
necessarily a requirement I think it's
still perfectly reasonable to load that
critical CSS resource you know as long
as the critical resource is small in the
head as an external resource if the page
will be slower for people who don't have
the resource in cache you know because
now they have to go to network to
download that additional resource but
you know you get some other benefits
right you're reducing bytes sent on the
wire for repeat views because you know
once it's in cache the user is enough to
download it again it you may introduce a
faster full cache experience for repeat
views it really depends it's not
guaranteed by any means sort of a little
counterintuitive you would think well
the HTML payload is smaller so the page
should load faster but it actually
depends it's not necessarily the case
there in any case either either of these
approaches is reasonable and it really
just depends you know you're making a
trade-off do I want the you know
fastest performance in which case you
want to inline or do I want a little bit
perhaps more maintainable approach in
which case you could keep it external
you know and pay a little bit of a
performance penalty for that so things
get kind of fuzzy or the further along
we go here so the last bit you know once
we've loaded our critical CSS you know
now we've got this other CSS needed to
style other parts of our app how do we
load that in a way that doesn't block
rendering of the page unfortunately
today there's not a great sort of simple
straightforward technique like we have
with script we have a sink right it's a
really easy you know first-class feature
of the platform the same does not exist
for stylesheet any stylesheet found in
the document by the parser will cause
the rendering engine to say okay I'm
going to wait and not paint anything
until I finished fully downloading this
stylesheet so you can't just throw link
rel stylesheet' href equals non-critical
CSS in the footer of your HTML the
parser will find that as soon as it does
if it hasn't painted the content above
yet it'll say whoa I'm not going to
paint anything even the markup above
that until that finishes downloading so
you have to be careful here
in the meantime so what we want is this
lazy load attribute and that's coming
soon some chrome engineers ie engineers
are working together on a spec and what
that says basically it's similar to
async and it basically says I need this
resource it shouldn't block rendering it
shouldn't block onload load it and when
it's available I'll make use of it in
the meantime we don't have that today
it's coming it's being Specht there are
a couple ways you can sort of work
around this you listed here
requestanimationframe so you sort of
wait for the first paint you could load
the resource in a hidden iframe you
could actually load it as JavaScript
I've seen people do this right
JavaScript has a sink right so you can
load a CSS resources Java server as I
say each of these I'm sort of part of me
as feeling not great this is really not
the kind of api's we want for this kind
of thing but fortunately you know the
lazy load attribute is coming and
that'll be the right thing to use once
that's shipped right so some high-level
recommendations for render blocking CSS
how are we doing on time Cole's nuts
right
avoid enlightening data uris right keep
them external keep the CSS as small as
possible you know critical CSS you know
what that is keeping that in mind and
making sure you're focusing on only
delivering that but you know all this
said right and if you're sort of hearing
me talk about this critical CSS and I
have to load some early in some late and
you know that sounds like a lot of
overhead the good news is if your total
CSS is reasonably small like if it's
under say 15k compressed right which
might mean 45 K uncompressed it's
probably small enough that you can just
treat it all as critical just you know
don't worry about partitioning out it's
only when it becomes really big that you
don't want to load all of it in a way
that blocks rendering anything at all to
the screen right so the common case I
hope is that you know your CSS is
already small and you just load that
upfront and don't worry about this
concept of non-critical CSS if you do
have a lot of CSS you want to load that
in a render blocking manner and we
talked about sort of the two techniques
for that and then load the remaining CSS
in that non blocking manner using for
the time being one of those you know
requestanimationframe or whatever it may
be techniques longer term using that
lazy load attribute so just a summarized
really high level the things that we
found are really important eliminate
render blocking JavaScript right so load
JavaScript asynchronously get it out of
the critical rendering path so design
your apps with that in mind right don't
depend on JavaScript having to load
synchronously in order to render your
page and along those lines you know
render the initial view to HTML right on
the server so don't use JavaScript
client-side to render the initial view
it's an inherently slow process we saw
Twitter had problems performance
problems with this Airbnb my team had
the same issues and then finally you
know serve up as little CSS as you need
to render the initial view be mindful of
you know just how much you're serving
and largely you can accomplish that by
just not inlining large data URIs and
your CSS I think if you if we stop doing
that I think our CSS is for the most
part will become manageable and will be
reasonable to load in a render blocking
way so that's that's everything
you